Subscribe to Pewds
♪ Fancy Ass Music ♪
Here's a video I am very excited about. If you watched my Instagram
or any social media (which you should), you know I like whisky
and my favorite is...
Japanese whisky. Which we're (Oh you mean YOU'RE GONNA DRINK AND WE'RE GONNA BE JEALOUS AF ?) gonna drink today. Hell yeah boy!
It's one of those videos where I don't know if this is a good idea, but I just want to drink some whisky-
So I thought we start with the Japanese type whiskey.
It's personally my favorite, probably a little little biased 'cause I love Japan.
Uhh- okay. So left side we have uhh...
Yeah, the Suntory whiskey.
Nevermind, there you go.
And right side we have the Ni- actually this doesn't belong.
We had the Nikka- Nikka whiskey. Those are the two big distilleries are uh companies rather
sorry in Japan. Suntory and Nikka.
They're all very different, but the first one ever made was the Yamazaki and I have a 12 year old one.
Which is uhh.. Very nice. VERY NICE :))))
*TOO CLOSE*
And then we have an 18 year old one which I've never even tried before, I've never had 18 year old aged whiskey
so I'm really excited. Oh Suntory,
you may have heard of, from the the movie 'Lost in Translation', when Bill Murray's on the.. he's doing the commercial and he's like "For
relaxing time...
make it Suntory time". So I thought we'd start with Yamazaki because it's the oldest of oldest, it's from
It started. So it's- it's the oldest- I think it's the oldest distillery in Japan
I don't know for sure. I'm curious if I will tell the difference between the 12-year and 18. I had this one before it's very nice
But I'll just say that about any whiskey really. It's very niceee
It's given me a very sweet palate. I'll just be like it's very nice. I like how they keep their bottles simple. Just fucking that's it.
Okay...
Get in there. And dats gonna be nice girl. We have a lot of stuff to try so let's just
That's very nice. It's got a *tasting noises* Oaky taste to it very- very beautiful
I would give it seven "very nice"s.
We have the 18 years
Let's just get the big guns out right away. Very nice, got the Suntory on the back.
18 years. This bottle, guess how much it costs, Marzia?
Damn it. Did I tell you?
It's 500. It's pretty crazy
I think in Japan you'll get it for like hundred and twenty. I never spent this much nearly on a whiskey
I'm like nervous even trying it.
Ohh it smells. It's beautiful
You can definitely tell a difference. Much smoother taste, you can really feel it more. It's just beautiful whisky
Very nice. VERY NAISE. I'm liking this, this is fun
The next one that came out was the Hibiki. This is not aged whiskey
It's sort of cheap, and I think it's a blend as well a meticulous blend of the finest whiskey
But Hibiki is very good. I think a lot- if you know Japanese whiskey you'll definitely know about
Hibiki I should probably pour a little less
'Cause I-
We got a lot of whiskies to go through I was gonna make it for the video, but I started early
I mean, they all taste very nice. It gives uh, the- the aftertaste. It's sort of a taste
that hits you when you have it in your mouth
And then there's a taste when you swallow (That's what she said) ;)
and it's so much more superior in this one compared to the Hibiki, even though the taste of them all is actually quite similar.
Maya can you be quiet, or do you want some whiskey?
Then we have the Hakushu, aged in the forest
hence the green uhh
Bottle and all that shit. Third HaKUshu, HAkushu?
Beautiful. Love the bottle, isn't it beautiful?
Yeah, you don't like it?
I love it. It's very- it's got a very light color to it. This is the last one of the Suntory
Whoa
That flavor is so different!
I really like that Hakushu. I think I would get an aged one of that next time
I think it's the same thing here. Since this isn't aged, you you're not hit by that taste afterwards the same way that I like
This is very nice. I give this one
7 wery- "very nice"s... 8 "very nice"s, 7 "very nice"s. This is a 6 "very nice"
Now we're moving on to the Nikka! Which unfortunately I only got two of them, and one I
I finished. I have a little- a little bit left of this one. Yoichi was the first one
they made, so Nikka was made by the legendary whiskey Japanese maker
Takeshuru? His name.. Masataka Taketsuru. So this guy was like... "I want to make whiskey!"
So he went to Scotland to study it, and then his met- he met his main bitch Rita
And then- who was also studying making whiskey, then they went back to Japan
And he joined the Suntory team, and he's like now fuck you guys. I'm gonna make my own brand
So he made Nikka, and the first one they did was Yoichi
1934, so
Suntory's older, but Ni- I think Nikka is
It's cooler B)
So, they made Yoichi and they tried to recreate the
The same thing they did in Scotland
The same condition. They have it there it's on- made on the island, like the Southern Island, I think?
Which is just as big as Scotland by the coast
They wanted it to be as authentic to scotti- scotch as possible, and scotch is literally just whisky, but it's made in
Scotland
yeah, but they have to be that just to be called the scotch
Prolly won't taste good because I left too much air in this bottle you shouldn't do that
Yeah, I got nothing in here, hehe
Well, it was good. I finished it
Welcome to I'll monetize my alcoholism.
Yoichi gets eight and a half "very nice"s
Damn~ it bites the tongue
Very nice. Eight and a half. I would almost say it's better than this one
And this is a cheap one
It's not aged. The other one I have is the Nikka Coffee Malt
Which, if you like Whiskey..
I recommend you try it out, It's very different. It's not coffee. It's named after the crea- uh, one of the investors or something like that
But I feel like it tastes like coffee. I might be paranoid. I feel that I thought it was- "Oh
so it's like a coffee flavor"
It's made from corn
mainly. It's cheap as well, if you want to get
something. I feel- I don't want to mess up the facts. I feel bad if I like,
get something wrong. I probably got some stuff wrong, but yeah, that's the
Coffee one. If I remember correct- it has- oh it smells beautiful. I think it smells so nice
I don't know if I even can tell them apart at this point
They're all so good
I'll give it seven "very nice". It gets- it gets a strong seven "very nice". So this is a blend
Single Malt, single Malt, single Malt, single Malt, so it's made from the same
Which one, this one? It's a blend. Single Malt didn't used to be very popular. when they started these it wasn't really a thing
But now it's like, if you want a good whiskey you probably want a single Malt
I think there's a lot of great blends as well. Don't get don't get me wrong
Which actually brings me to the final which is that Togouchi
Which I couldn't find any information about. It's sort of a ~mysterious~ bottle
They actually don't have their own distillery.. They- they don't- whoa. Is this 18 years? I didn't even know!
So I have that 18 years aged
you'll see it has uhh
Canadian writing on it. That's because they import from Scotland and Canada
Whisky. And then they masterfully blended into the Togouchi. I love it. Look at the bottle, it's so beautiful
It's sort of has a- if I remember correctly it has like a grassy taste to it? Which doesn't sound good
But it's- it's very.. I'm so glad I didn't finish this bottle. Hey this one grew on me.
I didn't really love it in the beginning, but then- okay
Yeah, it just has this weird... taste like nature
It's really good. It's so different from any of these like these- like these
I couldn't really probably tell apart to be honest. This one definitely has a unique- I can't believe it's 18 years
I had no idea! That's crazy. So that concludes my
Japanese
Whiskey we got the Suntory. We got the Nikka
I wish I brought more Nikka, my favorite Nikka is the Nikka from Barrel.
I really recommend that one. Check it out
If you want- if you're like, "Oh, I don't know which one to get! I want to start-" Try that one. It's very good
It's got a lotta alcohol in it *Click* Got a good kick to it. Now we're gonna do the test
I feel like. You'll have to set up the blind test
I mean, the color is already a dead giveaway, isn't it? This one is darker, isn't it? Or maybe?
If I had to guess just looking, I would say this is the 18, and this is the
So why don't we start with this one?
I don't want to mess this up. It's like 50/50
It's good. It's so good. You can tell yeah, I can tell it's Yamazaki because it has that cherry
It's not even cherry its more-
Y- you can taste the casket, which doesn't sound good at all but, strong flavor in this one actually
Maybe that was the 18 years one. I don't know. I don't know I need to try this one
Come on. What do I win?
Marzia: Nothing!
Okay
That's hard. Here's the thing. I want to go with my intuition
Which tells me this is the 12 year one... No the opposite, the flavor is telling m this is 18.. okay
This is the 18.
I got it?!
Okay, for real I get a lot of questions like "oh, I want to try whiskey. I don't- I tried Jack daniels and I tried
Jameson", but it's that's like saying  "Oh, I like Burgers, but I'm- I love- I'm trying McDonald's and Burger King"
Listen, there's this whole beautiful world
waiting for you, okay, Suntory and Nika. Thank you both. God bless you Japan. God bless you. Thank you very much
Leave a like if you enjoyed, I don't know if this even is video--
Alright. Thank you for watching leave a like if you enjoyed and I wanted to do scotch next,
so let me know if you want me to actually do that and Jiu jitsu
Jiu jitsu squad fam Jiu jitsu Bye